pensez-y mangeant du continent de
plastique qui s'est formée dans l'océan
pacifique qui est devenu en quelque
sorte le symbole de la crise du
plastique qui touche toute la planète
on retrouve des déchets qui flotte dans
tous nos océans la navigatrice mylène
paquette en sait quelque chose
il est avec nous ce matin bonjour
village où vous avez accepté d'être un
porte parole du festival zéro déchet de
montréal n'ont qu'à lyon en fin de
semaine est ce que c'est ce que vous
avez vu lors de votre traversée de
l'océan atlantique en 2013 qui vous a
sensibilisé aux déchets oui puis je dois
dire que j'en ai pas vu autant que les
images qu'on vient de voir ce qui se
passe qu'est que c'est un problème pas
mal plus important mais moi ce qui m'a
fasciné en 2013 bowie la quantité de
déchets j'en avais déjà vu dans une
autre à l'inversé précédente aussi et
c'est aussi de constater d'abord passé
129 jours sur le sien est d'arriver sur
le continent européen et de vider les
poubelles de mon embarcation à me dire
ça c'est juste moi pendant quatre mois
et 6 jours le volume que ça peut
représenter
donc c'est soit que je peux repartir à
zéro des chiens ou de melgven quand j'ai
traversé le faire la rente donc j'avais
des sachets de nourriture et tanches
dans lesquels ben je pouvais mettre dans
une cocotte faire bouillir et tout ça
donc c'était beaucoup plus simple en
terme de nourriture j'avais pas de
cuisine à faire
donc quand on prend conscience de tout
ce que vous avez vu dans l'océan quand
est ce que j'ai vu le plus souvent c'est
les sacs ziploc ces fameux ça qu'on
achète et consomme en grande quantité
donc autant les formats sans nous et
tous les formats arachides ou chocolat
les petits formats
j'en voyais parfois atterrir dans mon
cockpit après qu'une vague soit se soit
abattue sur le bateau donc à l'avenir un
porte parole du festival à rodez jeu ça
allait un peu de soi après ce que vous
avez vu parlez nous de ce festival qui
vise d'enfants à nous sensibiliser tout
à fait lé festival en fait une porte
d'entrée pour avoir une certaine mais
pour les gens qui sont curieux et qui
veut savoir c'est quoi le mode de vie
zéro déchet est une porte d'entrée donc
pour le zéro déchet donc on peut aller
voir des conférences des ateliers aussi
visité à 90 exposants
donc autant des producteurs de couches
lavables que des gens chez qui on peut
s'approvisionner en mouchoirs
réutilisables que tout d'autres
exposants qu'ils peuvent vendre des
produits faits à partir de matières
recyclées ça
bob bien au delà d'amener son sac oui
utilisable d'actionnement coulaud et
cette bouteille son thermos à café donc
aller jusqu'où ça peut aller mais je
vous dirais qu'il ya des gens qui sont
bien adaptés le zéro déchet c'est
vraiment bien intégré dans leur vie
alors je vois des gens qui utilisent qui
mettre à la poubelle tout simplement
en fait le comparable d'un groupe aux
maçons par année donc c'est un rugby
board wii par année donc il ya des gens
qui vraiment sortes de petits petits
déchets par année alors on a même une
conférence de quelqu'un qui vient nous
parler de sa famille zéro déchet et on
vient nous parler aussi à des
conférences sur comment bourrin un
enfant et l'élever avec le moins de
plastique possible parce qu'on sait que
le plastique autres le fait que ce sont
des déchets qui se retrouvent dans
l'environnement lorsqu'ils se dégradent
vont aussi y mettre des gps mais aussi
des perturbateurs endocriniens
donc ce n'est pas seulement que pour
l'environnement mais c'est pour notre
santé aussi qu'on doit réduire notre
consommation plastique il ya 7000
visiteurs qui se sont rendus au salon
l'an dernier jugement jeudi que vous
attendez à davantage de gens m'aiment et
jusqu'à 13 mai les réservations et
bright donc des gens qui ont réservé
leurs billets on sent un engouement on
en parle de plus en plus de ça mais on a
pu voir des démonstrations si je pense à
des collègues journalistes qui ont
essayé le de vivre
un mois s'est produit trop de déchets
c'est pas encore évident non c'est pas
encore évident mais plus on veut le
demander si le consommateur qui se
présentent une marche à l'épicerie avec
son plein moi j'ai toujours ma
fourchette avec moi donc je refuse tout
les toutes les fourchettes en plastique
à utilisation unique
au début je voudrais un dans le dos j'ai
encore gêné de la sortir ma fourchette
mais aujourd'hui je vois que le regard
des gens a changé
même quand je vais à l'épicerie pour le
prêter à manger le prétend porter je
refuse souvent le plan qu'on m'offre
quand j'ai mon plus beau reste de lui
avec moi par exemple et plus en plus je
vois qu'un accueil de ce non plus le
citoyen le consommateur voit le demander
plus les marchands vont être créés à
faire le geste et vont accepter ça va
devenir quelque chose monnaie courante
et c'est un grand défi avec les
supermarchés en trop on parle de la
viande tous à des gens qui veulent
arriver avec leur plein s'est refusé
dans la majorité des places directement
mais dans le prêt-à-manger et dans les
fruits et légumes y ait quelque chose à
faire puis juste parce qu'ils avaient
entendu parler aussi des plastiques
attaque donc c'est quelque chose que le
mouvement qui est né en europe et à
montréal du beaucoup de plastique
attaque aujourd'hui le panel sur le
plastique et j'ai une invitée qui initie
qu en fait c'est que des gens se
présentent à l'épicerie pour consommer
et lorsqu'ils passent à la caisse ils
vont déballer leurs produits donc pour
remettre à la question ou pour remettre
dans un bac de recyclage et partir avec
son produit sans matières recyclables ou
des matières résiduelles voilà votre
coup de coeur parmi tout ce qui va être
abordé lors du festival
je crois que c'est l'appartement zéro
déchet dans tout l'appartement témoin
que l'ipo vu encore mais j'en ai entendu
parler donc on évoque un appartement
zéro déchet ça ressemble un appartement
des années soixante dix avec du macramé
vie des affaires ça peut être très très
très au goût du jour et ça peut être
impressionnant de voir qu'il ya des
choses des meubles de monique sont faits
à partir de déchets mais encore qu'une
cuisine des roues déchire ça ressemble à
une cuisine un peu comme chez tout le
monde alors rapidement c'est aujourd'hui
le 3 novembre mais demain le 4 novembre
les portes ouvrent à 9h30 au marché
bonsecours et aujourd'hui jusqu'à 18
heures demain jusqu'à 17 ans notez
mylène paquette merci beaucoup en face
aux sages un plaisir